El pasado 1 de julio de 2017 se celebró un
aniversario muy especial.
Se cumplieron 20 años desde que Hong Kong
dejó de ser parte del Reino Unido y volvió
a formar parte de la República Popular de
China bajo el modelo “un país, dos sistemas”.
(Cómo sabéis, aunque China es una dictadura,
Hong Kong se incorporó al país como Una
Región Administrativa Especial donde rige
la llamada Ley Básica que les otorga a los
ciudadanos de Hong Kong un catálogo de derechos
y libertades inimaginables en el resto del
país, con la excepción, eso sí, de Macao).
Además, amigos, Hong Kong tiene su propia
moneda, su propia política de inmigración
y también policía, aduanas y tribunales
propios.
Vamos que en el día a día funciona casi
como un país independiente….
Pero esperad un momento, porque he dicho casi.
La intromisión de Pekín está siendo cada vez más intensa
y no penséis que en Pekín se andan con rodeos,
no.
Agentes ¿secretos?
chinos han llegado a secuestrar y torturar
a activistas prodemocracia.
De todo esto y de la llamada Revolución de
los Paraguas nos habló ya Couto, aquí en
VisualPolitik.
Os dejo el enlace al final del vídeo y también
en la descripción.
El caso es que para celebrar este 20 aniversario…
o más bien para dejar claro quién manda,
Xi Jinping hizo su primera visita a Hong Kong
desde que es… el presidente de China.
XI JINPING EN HONG KONG
Pues bien, la visita de Xi Jinping a Hong
Kong estuvo cargada de simbolismo y es que
se ha producido en un momento en que las críticas
contra China arrecian en Hong Kong.
La visita, amigos, duró tres días y en ese
corto espacio de tiempo el presidente chino
se ha encargado de dejar las cosas bastante
claras.
(“Cualquier intento de poner en peligro
la soberanía y seguridad de China, desafiar
el poder del gobierno central… o usar Hong
Kong para llevar a cabo actividades de infiltración
y sabotaje contra el continente es un acto
que cruza la línea roja y es absolutamente
inadmisible” Xi Jinping).
Vamos, en otras palabras, que para Pekín
todo eso de la libertad de expresión y la
democracia tiene límites, y desde luego no
van a permitir que ningún activista o político
se desmadre y se le ocurra poner en cuestión
el control de Pekín.
Y, ojo, la acción de Xi Jinping no se limitó
ni mucho a esta amenaza….
Para nada.
(El presidente de China aprovechó también
su visita para presidir el mayor desfile militar
de la historia de Hong Kong… Con tropas
chinas claro, y para asistir a la la toma
de posesión de Carrie Lam, la nueva jefa
ejecutiva de la ciudad… lo que viene a ser
la presidenta de Hong Kong, por así decirlo).
Pues bien, Xi Jinping, como “autoridad superior”
-aunque conforme a la Ley Básica tiene prohibido
interferir en la política local - aprovechó
para pedirle dos cosas a la nueva jefa administrativa
de Hong Kong:
(Por un lado, aprobar una ley anti subversión,
para poder condenar a todos los díscolos
que se atrevan a defender cosas como democracia
o independencia para Hong Kong; y por otro
un plan de “educación patriótica” para
los jóvenes…)
Sí, tal cual como lo escucháis.
Es lo que tienen las dictaduras, les gusta
que los niños estén bien ensañados en la
obediencia al régimen.
Claro que los hongkoneses no están precisamente
por la labor…
(A pesar de las advertencias del presidente
de China, coincidiendo con su visita, el 1
de julio 60.000 personas recorrieron las calles
de la ciudad pidiendo, básicamente, democracia
y garantías para preservar su grado de libertad).
(“Si la gente de Hong Kong no se levanta
por sí misma, no sale a la calle y pelea,
entonces Hong Kong se convertirá en China”.)
Así están las cosas en Hong Kong… y desde
luego en VisualPolitik estaremos muy atentos
a cómo evolucionan las cosas.
Ya sabéis, no olvidéis suscribiros al canal
para estar al tanto.
Pero llegados a este punto, y dado que se
ha celebrado el 20 aniversario de la soberanía
china, sobre la mesa hay una pregunta que
no podemos dejar de hacernos, una pregunta
obligatoria:
¿Qué tal le ha ido a Hong Kong durante estos
20 años?
¿Ha cambiado mucho?
¿En que se situación se encuentra?
Veámoslo.
HONG KONG SIGUE SIENDO HONG KONG
Tal vez la mejor noticia tras estos 20 años
es que Hong Kong sigue siendo, simple y llanamente,
Hong Kong, una ciudad distinta al resto de
China.
Os lo digo por experiencia propia, es difícil
resistirse a esa mezcla de caos, capitalismo
y cultura china que de forma tan viva se respira
en esta ciudad.
(Hong Kong sigue siendo la ciudad más rica
y más libre de China.
Sus tribunales funcionan, los medios de comunicación
no están sometidos a censura y el debate
político es animado, tan animado que las
protestas contra China son relativamente habituales).
De hecho, ver una manifestación por la libertad
de más de 60.000 personas como colofón a
la visita de Xi Jinping es buena muestra de
ello.
Además, amigos, durante este tiempo el crecimiento
económico ha promediado un respetable 3,3%
anual,
un crecimiento que, aunque es algo inferior
al de otras potencias asiáticas como Singapur
o no asiáticas, como Irlanda, es superior
al que han tenido la mayoría de las economías
más ricas.
Buena prueba de ello es que durante este tiempo
más de 1 millón de chinos se han traslado
a Hong Kong en busca de fortuna, o también
que la ciudad haya logrado consolidar su importancia
como ciudad financiera mundial.
(El número de empresas que cotizan en la
bolsa de Hong Kong se ha multiplicado por
3 desde 1997, y su capitalización alcanzó
los 3,2 billones dólares en 2016, el equivalente
casi a todo el PIB de Alemania).
Y además con casi 60 millones de turistas,
Hong Kong se ha convertido en toda una potencia
en este sector…
Claro que, esperad un momento... porque también
hay síntomas de que el modelo de esta ciudad
puede estar, agotándose.
¿EL OCASO DE UN MODELO ÚNICO?
Es verdad que el crecimiento económico de
la isla desde 1997 ha sido razonable, pero
también es cierto que se ha ido ralentizando,
que el ahorro se ha desplomado y que el futuro
no parece el más halagüeño, y no solo por
la situación política.
(“La economía de Hong Kong se enfrenta
al peor momento en 20 años”.)
De hecho, cada día es más general la sensación
de que Hong Kong no ha sabido reinventarse
y que corre el riesgo de convertirse en una
especie de parque temático para financieros
y turismo de poca monta.
Tal vez donde mejor se aprecia la pérdida
de empuje de la ciudad es cuando se la compara
con el resto de ciudades del Delta del Río
de las Perlas, la región a la que pertenece
Hong Kong y de la que tradicionalmente ha
sido el gran centro de actividad.
Hoy, sencillamente, ya no es así.
Fijaos, por ejemplo, en Shenzhen.
(Hace tres décadas esta ciudad china no era
más que un pobre pueblo pesquero de 50.000
habitantes, hoy es una impresionante ciudad
donde viven 15 millones de personas, tiene
tantas compañías en el Fortune 500 como
Hong Kong y es un destacado centro de alta
tecnología que alberga a compañías tan
importantes como Tencent o Huawei).
Pues, ojo, porque para muchos y cada vez más,
Shenzhen y no Hong Kong está llamada a ser
la gran referencia de la zona.
Y atentos a este otro dato, en 1997 Hong Kong
representaba el 20% de la economía china,
hoy no llega al 3%.
Así están cambiando las cosas.
(“La economía de Hong Kong está atascada,
apenas ha cambiado en las últimas dos décadas”.)
Y la verdad, no...
Esta especie de ocaso no tiene nada que ver
con la mala suerte, Hong Kong ha cometido
importantes errores.
Hay dos principales:
Uno es el mercado de la vivienda que es, literalmente,
un desastre.
(Hong Kong tiene unos precios inmobiliarios
tan disparatados que muchos de sus habitantes
saben que su única oportunidad es conseguir
una vivienda pública que probablemente sea,
minúscula).
Y, ojo, porque en Hong Kong los apartamentos
de 40 m2 no son algo extraño.
Y claro, cuando no hay viviendas suficientes,
todos los espacios inmobiliarios son carísimos
y es difícil acceder a ellos… Pues por
ejemplo es complicado que se instalen aquí
start-ups o nuevas empresas.
Además, todo esto hace que ocurran cosas
tan disparatadas como está:
(“Se vende el garaje más caro de la historia
de Hong Kong por más de 600.000$”.)
(Ojo, no es que no haya terreno, ese no es
el problema, menos del 25% de la superficie
de Hong Kong está urbanizada y además existen
muchas más posibilidades, como la de ganar
terreno al mar.
No, definitivamente ese no es el principal
problema)
Mirad, Hong Kong tiene una economía muy libre,
la más libre del mundo según el índice
de libertad económica, pero no lo es en absoluto
si hablamos de suelo, vivienda y urbanismo.
En Hong Kong, el gobierno es el encargado
de llevar la batuta en el sector inmobiliario
y el fracaso que han tenido en las últimas
décadas ha sido de escándalo.
("Hay más de 200 hectáreas de tierras disponibles
para la construcción en las zonas urbanas.
La escasez de viviendas es real, pero es debido
a la deliberada manipulación del mercado
por parte del gobierno ".)
Fijaos, bajo una política que data de la
etapa colonial hay desarrollos inmobiliarios
parados porque el gobierno local arrendó
por décadas tierras a granjeros para plantar,
por ejemplo, arroz y hoy estas comunidades
apoyan a Pekín y ningún gobierno quiere
problemas… ¡de locos!
Y además también hay claras sospechas de
que se ha querido favorecer a determinados
oligarcas con grandes propiedades inmobiliarias…
(Entre los 14 magnates inmobiliarios más
ricos de Asia, siete son de Hong Kong.
Algunos juicios y condenas han mostrado evidencias
de corrupción y confirmado los muy sospechosos
vínculos entre funcionarios gubernamentales
y magnates inmobiliarios de Hong Kong).
Porque, amigos, este es el otro gran problema
de Hong Kong, el creciente capitalismo de
amiguetes…
UN FUTURO LLENO DE INCÓGNITAS
Hay un consenso bastante amplio: en los últimos
años el capitalismo en Hong Kong ha perdido
fuerza frente a una fórmula con nombre similar
pero muy diferente en fondo y forma: el capitalismo
de amiguetes.
(“Bajo los británicos el gobierno era pro-negocio,
pero no se inmiscuía en los negocios.
Desde 1997 los intereses empresariales se
han incorporado al sistema político y los
conflictos de intereses se han multiplicado.
El capitalismo de amiguetes ha crecido”.).
Hoy en muchos sectores la competencia ha sido
sustituida por oligopolios y monopolios bien
relacionados.
Y lo peor es que a medida que las autoridades
chinas ganan protagonismo en la ciudad, las
cosas están yendo a peor.
Por ejemplo, con la intención de ganar influencia
y peso político, la llamada Oficina de Enlace,
que viene a ser la representación, la delegación
del gobierno chino, está incluso proporcionando
préstamos en condiciones ventajosas a las
empresas “amigas”.
¿Qué necesitas para recibir uno?
Pues estar bien conectado.
Y para añadir más sombras al futuro está,
sin duda, el conflicto político del que tanto
os hemos hablado.
(Los jóvenes cada vez sienten menos lazos
de identidad con China, pasa algo similar
a lo que ya os contamos sobre Taiwán… y
eso solo hace presagiar un debate político,
, más polarizado, más caliente).
En fin, enfrentarse a todo esto es la misión
de Carrie Lam, la nueva Jefe Ejecutiva de
Hong Kong, claro que su legitimidad parece
dudosa, al fin y al cabo, ha sido elegida
no por el pueblo sino por un grupo que responde
a las directrices del Gobierno de Pekín.
Hubo un día, amigos de VisualPolitik, que
se pensó qué Hong Kong sería el modelo
para el cambio político en China, hoy desgraciadamente
las cosas parecen algo diferentes y la pregunta
es ¿Cuál será el futuro de Hong Kong?
¿Ganarán las luces o las sombras?
Turno para ti, puedes dejarnos tu opinión
en los comentarios y también en esta encuesta.
¡Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like!
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.